Hi!
Over 20 years ago, Marty Mcfly wore a pair of these in Back to the Future 2.
Now, it is the future and Nike has joined my foundation in our mission to cure Parkinson's.
We're auctioning off 150 pairs of the 2011 Nike Mags here on eBay,...
...every day through September 18th.
Proceeds will help our foundation fund research that could transform the lives of those with Parkinson's.
Please bid, the timing couldn't be better.
A matching gift in effect right now can double your contribution.
Together, we can create a future without Parkinson's.
On behalf of our foundation,...
...Nike, eBay and the five million people living with Parkinson's worldwide,...
...thank you.